non c'est de la bombe
venant de visionner un document
accablant puisque en plus vous avez pris
la peine de filmer vos exploits
je suppose que vous n'avez pas d'avocat
qui va assurer votre protection la
protection pour ma protection j'utilise
normes epn qui me permet de contourner
les jets aux restrictions pour par
exemple avoir le défectueuse pour le
catalogue ou le des trucs japonais pour
les animer monsieur vous êtes quand même
accusé d'homicide volontaire là qu'avez
vous à dire pour votre défense
une défense qui a besoin de défense
quand on dort bpn
grâce à ça je peux sécurisé mais
connexions dans les wifi public jusqu'à
six appareils en simultané avec 1
seconde
en plus de la garantie est de 30 jours
satisfait ou remboursé
vous risquez quand même trente ans de
prison ferme là à 30 ans 4 mois
oui avec l'offre spéciale de noël pour
toute souscription à un abonnement de
deux ans recevez un bonus 4 mois
supplémentaires gratuits en utilisant le
code promo joueurs ou en cliquant sur le
lien ci dessous
quatre mois supplémentaires gratuits ces
nombres a quittés
[Musique]
mes amis nous sommes arrivés
trickett se trouve dans ce donjon
ça va serrer la vis de mon tiroir ouais
c'est pas un donjon ça c'est une pauvre
verges sorcier tu te fous nous cours à
saissac exerça ans on a vendu donne aux
trois gènes pour jouer au casino
au méliès calme et oui un immense trésor
nous attend ici mais il faudra le
mériter
voire même coconnier n'avait pas
confiance en moi c'était moi chaque fois
seule fois je vous ai planté
c'est à dire qu'il y en a plein en fait
mais voilà papa densité humaine en
particulier un allez on y va
[Musique]
mais quoi
mais bordel puisque je vous dis que je
suis villageois
tout avait dit invité sur la prochaine
autoroute
vous allez voir on sera riche en un rien
de temps condamnait ou feu vous êtes là
j'avais gage que chez vous comme rien au
mont blanc
aller au travail
vous allez comprendre pourquoi on
appelle le magicien
j'ai tout perdu quoi tu es en train de
nous expliquer que tu as perdu tout
notre fric sorcier écoute moi bien vieux
sac à merde ça fait des années que je
supportais conneries et ton odeur de
vieux champignons mets là et tu vas
bouger ton cul et récupérer notre pognon
je pleurais niort
[Musique]
mais
je
[Musique]
moscovici il ya bien longtemps la
personne qui dirige cet établissement a
retrouvé trois des quatre j'aime de
pouvoir avec ses compagnons et en moyens
de les retrouver ses petits pardon mais
depuis ces connards de ses organes il
accorde des cinq maisons ils s'en font
qu'à leur tête
franchement je suis texas grandeur
bienvenue au lycée magique publique
georges pompidou bonjour mademoiselle
vous pouvez peut-être nous aider on
cherche à rencontrer des acteurs à oui
biensur suivez moi une seconde enseigne
c'est pour ça que lors des salles de
shoot professeur professeurs
ce qui vous est arrivé ce qui s'est
passé ici qui vous a fait ça sais tu ce
qui j'espère qu'il sait c'est pour ça
que je voulais 10 et tu sais qui tu sais
qui quoi mais n'ont pas tous ceux qui
quoi il a rien fait ils en sécu c'est
qui
merci qui peu importe écoutez nous
sommes sur une mission des plus
importantes
il ya longtemps vous avez été en
possession de trois gemmes de pouvoir
l'ennemi a déjà mis la main sur deux
d'entre elles la rouge et la jaune qui
est ce que vous avez fait de la verte
vous êtes sûr parce qu'ils nourrissent
tous que ça quand même c'est pas un
petit peu craignos parce que cette
pierre me rappelle la mystérieuse
légende des quatre j'aime de pouvoir qui
une fois réunis permettent d'exaucer
n'importe quel de gilberte oui je m'en
rappelle c'était il ya fort longtemps
j'affrontais un karibe l'ennemi lors
d'un duel au sommet
tous mes amis étaient derrière moi et me
soutenaient t'as intérêt à réussir ton
coup le sorcier
parce que si tu te fois sur je tranche
la gorge tu pourras pas il a déjà vendu
nos armes
en fait tu es sûr de moi j'avais a battu
ma carte maîtresse
le risque était grand
il ne fallait pas perdre la face
mais l'ennemi était trop fort pour moi
et la rivière du destin m'emporter dans
les flots de ténèbres
[Musique]
merci pour cette partie vieillard oh
merde tu sais qui c'était tu sais qui il
était dans le passé le professeur tu
sais qui mais qu'est ce qu'il faisait
dans le passé je me suis fait choix vous
savez professeur votre vie privée ne
regarde pas forcément non pas ce soir le
prof de britanniques que je me suis fait
chaud à un mek les bagnoles il a volé
fatale à berne il a beau les motos lohan
serait kim catastrophe on est ok
démerdez vous ou vos merdes attendait
tout n'est pas perdu
j'ai une idée est ce que vous avez
toujours votre douleur et âme au quai
c'est trop longue laissez moi faire rage
combien de temps il nous reste moins de
30 minutes en comptant test on n'a pas
le temps oracle il faut absolument qu'on
trouve l'emplacement de cette dernière
j'aime je peux pas sûr trimestre et joua
vaste la base virale a été mise à jour
bon sang que dieu nous vienne en aide
moi je peux peut-être vous aider depuis
toute la chaîne
je peux tout vous dire
mais je peux quelque chose en échange
qu'est ce que vous voulez
je veux qu'on change de salle j'ai peut
être courte et aux cuisses à nana là on
va commencer à écouter les tableaux qui
parle on est où ici à la foire du trône
toute manière on les fout tu parles
tableau dino ce que tu as vu
il venait d'assommer le proviseur
je les ai vus voler les clés de la
voiture
hahaha j'ai les clés de l'appareil qui
me permettront de remonter dans le temps
pour voler la gemme verte juste après ça
j'irais voler la bleue car je sais où
elle se trouve et je vais prononcer
l'endroit exact à voix haute
immédiatement heureusement que ce
scénario ici mal écrit et oui cette
dernière j'avais alors
thibault maladie tout le monde sait ce
qu'il a à faire
non absolument pas parlé aux dites rien
depuis plusieurs jours c'est ce qu'il a
à faire
oui je peux aller aux toilettes
c'est ce qu'il a à faire oui je les
remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
will be blood abidjan bien sûr je vous
emmène à la cantine non non non non non
non surtout pas au local elle expliqué
d'accord pas de souci
oh
[Musique]
ah ah
coc
merci de rien
[Musique]
tous
l'objectif n'est pas loin il faut
traverser le maire du quart cachez vous
mettant ok alors là d'après le scénario
c'est la scène où vous infiltrer ya du
monde
david je vous assure que balkany mal
crossing ça ne fait rire que vous ici
bon ça va
ce principal david
qu'est ce que vous regardez maintenant
qu'est ce que c'est que cette musique là
comme il va falloir vous reprendre mon
garçon quand vous êtes arrivé là vous je
suis passé par un autre couloir où
l'impasse même produit ils ont activé le
courant de mes genoux
j'ai quand même un très grand bâtiment
de béton nature que c'est par là
dépêchons nous échouons nous vraiment on
n'a plus d'argent pour les effets
spéciaux
[Musique]
je crois qu'on est bientôt arrivée on
est arrivé et merde c'est fermé non mais
laissez moi utiliser mes pouvoirs
magiques détectée
allaire et merde on a déclenché une
alarme silencieuse à magie va les
retenir
[Musique]
magie du plomb [ __ ]
canard man d'après ce que je vois il ya
des centaines de chaînes dans cet
endroit du milieu
et comme vous allez faire pour trouver
la gemme vous n'allez quand même pas
tous les tester et pourquoi pas
[Musique]
comme john a fait quatre ah bon on va
trouver une autre solution alors enfin
nous nous rencontrons lors de notre duel
final a sonné je te donnerai ce jeu à la
condition que tu réussisses mes
différentes épreuves
commençons par la première mon premier
peut se mettre dedans un peu rock c'est
mon jeu de je danse et la simulation 24
de jouer avec nous des barmans pardon la
[Musique]
se dit qu on a beaucoup parlé de sonic
pendant ces dix dernières années que ce
soit en cartoon en jeu vidéo ou dans
d'étranges d'adaptation fétichistes et
moi ça va j'ai pas de problème avec ça
j'adore sony qu'il ya dans le fétichisme
et aujourd'hui on va jouer encore une
fois un mot jeu sonic sur xbox 360 xbox
je ne sais pas c'est un jeu rétro sas
est sorti ce sont louis ses sorties à 15
ans ah bon ça va alors mener xiiiè job
aussi appelé sonic 06 ou sonic 2006 par
le grand public peut être l'adaptation
du hérisson la plus infâme et la plus
connue mais
et c'était pas sens est le cas pourtant
un voyage ont un peu dans le temps nous
sommes en 2006 quinzaine la syrie
fallait donc marquer le coup il fallait
montrer que ça y est après des années
d'hésitations et d'opus en 3d bizarre
qui prenaient des directions carrément
chelou il fallait dire ça y est là on y
est c'est bon sonic a compris c'est un
nouveau départ et d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que je ne s'appellera pas sonic 4 ou
sonic adventure 3 ou ou sonic history
non ça s'appellera juste comme le
premier jeu sonic the hedgehog
alors heureusement rien ne se passera
comme prévu un jeu trop ambitieux délai
trop court pour sortir le jeu
impérativement pour la date anniversaire
équipes divisées en trois pour adapter
la version ps3 et wii qui en plus ne
sortira jamais bref sentant la
catastrophe nucléaire approché le
créateur historique de sonic dinaqua
démissionne avant la sortie du jeu et
sonic 2006 restera dans l'histoire comme
un des jeux qui aura tué
enfin du moins pendant quelques années
une des plus grandes mascotte du jeu
vidéo où ça sent bon
donc on lance un trou et le jeu commence
avec une cinématique
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me suis pas planter pourtant bon ben
ok donc on commence par une cinématique
de final fantasy où on retrouve élise
jeune princesse de soléa nains royaume
ressemble à un genre de venise fantasmes
érotiques débarque en ville en faisant
tout péter pour s'emparer du pouvoir de
cette dernière une chaos c'est le rôle
qu'elle porte autour du cou
évidemment sonic débarque détruit des
robots et sauve la princesse avant de
sentir
a je pense qu'on vient de quitter la
cinématique pour rentrer dans le moteur
du jeu
bref les deux se font rattraper elise se
fait kidnapper mais dans un dernier
sursaut celle-ci james en émeraude à
sonic de voix robotique qui ne réagit
pas alors que c'est précisément ce qu'il
était venu chercher le porte-avions de
robotnik s'éloigne alors devant sony qui
jurent de les sauver en les regardant
partir pendant longtemps
pendant très longtemps et sonique
prends ton temps et lis je vais te
sauver
[Musique]
bref le jeu commence au sein de sol et
ana au lendemain de l'explosion du
centre-ville et de l'enlèvement de leurs
princesses la cité dans une panique la
plus totale
[Musique]
la france a peur la cité est donc un
genre de hub vous allez évoluer entre
chaque mission vous y ferez des quêtes
secondaires qui permettront de débloquer
des compétences et déjà avant même de
parler du jeu j'ai un vrai problème
personnellement avec le carat design
dire le look des personnages je veux
dire bon dans la cinématique d'intro on
nous vend un look à la final fantasy
avec une cité fantasmée et des tenues
extravagantes auxquelles pourquoi pas
mais quand le jeu commence les gens sont
littéralement en jeans et en polo je
serais ce que ce personnage a l'air
d'être dans un jeu sonic déjà même pas
l'air d'être dans son propre jeu et
c'est pareil pour le design des
personnages alors je vais pas revenir
sur le fait que d'avoir des grosses
créatures cartoonesque avec des dieux
énorme à côté du mas normaux c'est
vraiment bizarre mais déjà réfléchi
c'est qu'est ce que ça implique
je dirai ce qu'ils vivent dans ce monde
est ce que les gens sont habitués à voir
ce genre de choses et que c'est pour ça
que personne n'est étonné dans ce cas
qu'est ce qu'il en est des autres
animaux basque bon ok alors dans ce cas
là ça c'est une orque ça c'est un chien
et salace un chat il ya vraiment un côté
angoissant dans le fait que personne ne
souligne l'existence de ces créatures
alors que mais pourtant elles sont que
quatre dans le monde
eh bien vous savez ici à solana on a
livré un sourire pire même bien plus tôt
mais là qu'est ce qui se passe avec la
bouche des pnj
oui moi aussi je sais bien qu'on est
censé être à venise en italie mais il ya
peut-être exagérations sur les clichés
d'ailleurs tu en connais dans les quêtes
secondaires
c'est quoi ce bordel avec les écrans de
chargement y en a partout ou changer de
rue sa charge vous parler à un pnj pour
prendre une quête sa charge le pnj vous
dit une phrase ça recharge encore mais
[ __ ] mais pourquoi ne pas avoir mis
cette ligne de dialogue à la fin du
dialogue précédent y avait vraiment
besoin d'un chargement entier juste pour
une phrase est là les chargements en
plus je voulais comprendre montage mais
c'est 20 secondes à chaque fois imaginez
si vous perdez si vous mourez dans un
niveau vous permet au jeu chargement le
pnj vous dis lol mdr t'es perdu fdp
chargement retour d'un soldat pour
reparler au pnj chargement deuxième
réplique chargement et re le jeu je
devienne si le jeu était honnête il
aurait dû s'appeler chargement le
hérisson bref le premier niveau commence
et sonic doit empêcher une orque de
s'échapper de son enclos en référence à
un level de sonic adventure un way
terminé de libérer les animaux là comme
un [ __ ] de bobos gauchistes en tôle
les lapins bref donc le jeu est bien c
[Musique]
bah
ben c'est pas amusant en fait et je
m'ennuie un peu mais est en même temps
je serai pas trop dire ce qui va pas et
je fais oui je sais mais c'est peut-être
parce qu'un jeu et joue sans moi alors
je m'excuse c'est peut-être une version
du fun qui m'échappe un peu dans le
nouveau jeu sonic mais là il ya
plusieurs passages dans ce niveau où
vous pouvez juste ne plus toucher du
tout la manette ça marche quand même
c'est pas truqué 1 ça fait genre 30
secondes que je plus là
[Musique]
plus tard dans le jeu c'est même pire un
sonic 2006 essaye de vous proposer une
expérience quasi cinéma est donc très
souvent on aura des moments le jeu part
dans un espèce de mode cinématiques
ultra vénère avec des changements
d'angles de caméra et toux ou des
passages sur des rails super rapide
sauf que malgré tout ça et tous ces
changements de caméras mais on est
toujours dans le jeu et donc si vous
touchez la manette à ce moment là
souvent ça vous fait sortir du rail
et paf c'est d'abord et du coup je sais
même plus quand j'ai le droit de jouer
ou pas ce jeu meurent apparemment je
vous jure devant dieu tu touches pas tu
regarde mes jeux
comme je l'avais dit pas touché la balle
elle voulait juste mais tu fais quoi la
joue mais [ __ ] c'est aussi comme ce
nouveau système de saut vous devez juste
appuyer au bon moment pour que sonic
sont automatiquement sur un ennemi à
porter alors ok je sais que ce truc est
présent depuis longtemps sur les
épisodes en 3d donc aller au quai pour
sonics dit rien mais tales il peut
carrément plus se mettre en boule à la
place maintenant ils balancent des
espèces de bombes à anneaux et c'est
tellement nul comme système déjà primo
chaque fois que tu lance une bombe ça
fait le bruit de quand vous perdez des
annonces et les anneaux lancer ensuite
traînent au sol au milieu des vrais
anneaux que tu peux ramasser et rien ne
les différencie
et deuxio pour bien viser il faut passer
en vue fps en vue fps sur un jeu sonic
et je rappelle que dans les jeux sonic
les anneaux c'est un petit point dis
donc c'est littéralement comme si ton
personnage se couper les gènes pour
attaquer l'ennemi et regarder la scène
si vous ratez la mission avec l'or quand
ça vous donne une idée du niveau
d'implication dans la création de ce jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bref une fois arrivé au bout du niveau
l'or qui est capturé mais attendez une
minute
viens jouer james panda capturés lors
bravo sony mais on n'était pas aussi
retrouver la princesse merde donc après
le premier niveau le jeu s'est
visiblement souvenu qu'il avait un
scénario est aussi qu'un jeu sonic
c'était censé aller vite il nous propose
donc un nouveau gameplay qui sent bon le
jus de poubelle mariné au mois d'août
dans ces passages vous ne contrôlez plus
entièrement sonica vous pouvez juste le
diriger à droite ou à gauche et sauter
et à défaut d'être bien fait au moins
ces passages sont vraiment drôles sonic
mais en fait je devrais dire tous les
personnages du jeu sont beaucoup trop
sensible
pas comme ça annonce du film d'après de
prolait du bout du poil le contrôleur de
la manette pour que ce dernier ces
cartes plus vite du chemin qu une
trieuse devant avec moche à la japan
expo et chaque fois que tu frôles le
moindre caillou ton hérisson part dans
une espèce de carambolages ridicule
[Musique]
ça donne pas la sensation d'être sonic
ou d'aller vite c'est juste la sensation
de plus contrôler les pieds ses
positions en corse et que le premier
niveau dans ce style là ça revient plus
tard en pire
le jeu vous chine et polygone à la
gueule comme un concept à froid dès
qu'ils auront une gastro [ __ ] mais je
vois rien je vois rien à [ __ ]
bref donc éventuellement vous arriverez
à la fin du niveau pour voir le
porte-avions de robotnik s'éloigner avec
la princesse à son bord merci tales
si seulement on avait un moyen de voler
bref
après un nouveau
passage bas
ville de
solea n'at on arrive au niveau suivant
l'égide tout pour retrouver la princesse
vous devrez d'abord battre un boss
l'occasion pour nous de découvrir une
nouvelle facette du jeu est fausse
donc après avoir libéré la princesse et
assister à une des moult scènes de
tension sexuelle entre sonic et élise
dîner d'une page obscure de deviantart
[Musique]
là ça ne vous plaît pas et là ça vous
dérange là ce n'est pas bon on revient
donc à solérien ou silver un nouveau
personnage nous tombe dessus pour nous
tuer alors silver techniquement il est
déjà apparu dans la cinématique d'intro
du jeu mais à ce stade là on ne sait pas
encore pourquoi il veut nous tuer donc
je me permets de faire un petit flash
forward dans l'histoire pour vous
expliquer le scénario dans un futur
lointain silver vit dans un monde qui
est en guerre constante contre un
monstre gigantesque du nom de iblis
accompagné de blaise chat rose qui lui
fait office de mentor et de compagnons
et qui plus tard se sacrifiera pour lui
silver est épuisée de toujours se battre
et retourne donc dans le passé afin
d'empêcher son futur apocalyptique que
se produire incroyable
quelle originalité c'est alors que the
dark en trans aide et convainque silver
que c'est sonic qui a libéré iblis dans
le passé en lui montrant une image de
sonic dans des flammes
non mais non mais sérieux je suis désolé
mais c'est pas possible la silver je te
présente notre nouvel allié méchant
topps leçon blanc ce type bizarre que je
n'ai jamais rencontré me demande de tuer
un mec que je ne connais pas c'est long
ça bref le combat contre silver c'est un
cetain autant qu avec un nombre de
salles parce que vraiment ce jeu a un
truc génial c'est de ne pas avoir de
système pour l'oc la caméra sur les
ennemis zelda qui est sorti presque dix
ans avant avait un système de lock de
caméra y'a aucune excuse je peux pas la
prochaine phase parce que sinon unis
mobilisent avec cette fois ci donc je
dois lui tourner autour pour le
contourner mais si je tourne autour de
lui avec cette cannage le père de vue
mépris mais sérieux ne peut approcher
je peux pas le projet regardez monde
je n'ai même plus je touche plus la
salle je ne touche même plus le sol
médecin actuel mais laisse moi jouer et
une hausse mais je peux va mourir je
verrai couper un anneau à chaque fois
qu'ils se jettent sur le mur maintenant
je suis dans une courbe
je peux pas jouer je peux pas mourir
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce jeu mais
que quelqu'un fasse preuve d'humanité hf
cet animal vous voyez bien qu'il souffre
mon sort tout ça à cause de cette caméra
de ces morts il est où ton poste de
merde là il est où
et c'est même pas comme s'il était
incapable de le faire vu que sur
certains votes le lob de la kabylie est
alors pourquoi là non je vous jure que
la caméra c'est de très loin votre pire
ennemi dans ce jeu dans le meilleur des
cas c'est de la merde et dans le pire
c'est du sabotage à l'école pas le sol
[ __ ] et le plus absurde c'est que
chaque fois que la caméra change d'angle
vos contrôles de change avec imaginez
vous êtes en train de courir la caméra
et dans votre dos donc vous appuyer sur
vos pour avancer et subitement elle
décide de bouger et dark ton avant
devient ta droite à droite devient pas
en arrière c'est comme si un mec venez
chargé ta manette de position peu de les
capturer
[ __ ] je vous jure que si ce jeu avait
un visage lui colle raymond pile dedans
bon alors après un passage d'un haut
niveau de la neige qui est littéralement
la foire à la saucisse du bugue aux
rencontres alors robotnik qui détient
toujours élise en otage ce dernier nous
prend alors les modes du chaos et décide
de nous tuer en nous envoyer en voyager
dans le temps
et pourquoi les notes des oui ok
d'accord mais pourquoi roule house ou
nda et kobe est lourde enfin quoi pour
créer un scénario stupide est
inutilement compliquée passé sur les
personnages creux et de multiples
incohérences temporel à merci on est
donc envoyé dans le futur on rencontre
pour la première fois les personnages de
shadow et de rouge c'est la première
fois que je la vois ailleurs que dans un
hentai alors ça fait bizarre
donc en gros dans le futur on récupère
une kaos emerald en battant iblis qui
nous permet de voyager dans le présent
cas très chaud oui j'ai pas précisé ils
peuvent voyager dans le temps à volonté
les personnages passent leur temps à
faire des allers retours entre le passé
le présent et le futur
regardez à un moment dans le sénat ya le
vaisseau de robotique qui s'écrase en
tuant elisa sens
hélas il leur dit weir billets vont
suivre ouais donc yaya il n'y a vraiment
aucun enjeu en fait du coup on peut
juste pas échouer du tout en fait on
pourrait même juste revenir dans le
temps à l'époque de sonic rush sur votre
nuque est battable
il faut vous dire comment que les
voyages dans le temps ça ne marche pas
dans les scénarios vous expliqué m
global en gros mais vilaine de marquer
c'est de relier avec ghibli ce qui a été
cédée à l'intérieur deux hélices par son
père dans le passé fier filet 6 bliss
possèdent en eux les deux moitiés de
solaris dieu de léana par pitié on parle
d'un hérisson bleu qui courent vite
arrêté tout prendre au sérieux
bref donc iblis à l'intérieur deux
hélices ne peut être relâché que si
élise versailles armes et donc c'est
pour ça que mes finesse de dark et c'est
d'envoyer silver tué sonic c'est prendre
ellis triste c c'est ça donc c'est ça le
scénar envoyé un assassin du futur pour
tuer un hérisson afin de faire pleurer
une fille ok alors voilà toute une liste
de choses qui aurait été plus simple
pour atteindre cet objectif
et puis entre nous c'est quand même une
idée à la con de la part du père
oui bref de retour dans le présent donc
on libéralise encore et silver vient
nous défier en duel encore mais élise se
refait capture et encore il va peut-être
falloir envisager de la tâche et de
l'enfermer quelque part un moment tu
suis pas pour ce genre de choses hein
d'habitude un parent peut-être en privé
mais là quand même
donc on l'a l'hiver encore une fois mais
robotique des poules en ville en
menaçant de tout détruire
elise donc décide de et les semailles de
printemps sur 120
[Musique]
bref donc je pourrais vous parler de ce
jeu pendant une éternité en fait je
pourrais même faire un épisode entier
consacré à chaque niveau tellement que
ce jeu est une merde de rang s
mais ça serait répétée en boucle les
mêmes défauts plus tard le jeu vous
demandera de choisir pour savoir qui
vous aimez élise ou émis alors pour moi
j'ai pris ennemi parce que je n'ai
aucune envie de voir ce que donne un
croisement entre une humaine et un
hérisson et quand vous aurez fini l'arc
de sonic et bien vous pourrez jouer les
arcs 2 silver et de shadow qui sont
indispensables pour comprendre
l'histoire dans sa totalité
vous allez donc pouvoir refaire les
mêmes niveaux dans le désordre ce
coup-ci en jouant silver qui se bat avec
un pouvoirs télékinésiques ou shadow qui
est trop tard qu'ils mystérieuse gdiri
pilote des véhicules qui tirent des
missiles ou et il fait de la moto et sa
moto même qu'elle s'appelle la moto des
ténèbres et il est membre du gun
vous êtes tellement vieux [ __ ] vous
auriez dû lui faire des couilles énorme
aussi temps cogner shadow il est
tellement viril je suis sûre il a un
tatouage de couilles sur ses couilles
mais bref la phrase importante dans ce
que je viens de dire c'était à refaire
les mêmes niveaux
bref sony 2006 c'est une boule de
chiasse c'est une boule de chiasse qui
bug tout le temps c est un embarras de
tous les instants et en plus on vient
pas mais c'est vraiment dur entre les
bugs la caméra qui fait n'importe quoi
mais vraiment j'insisterai jamais assez
sur cette caméra elle dit la merde
sérieusement et le perso qui est
incontrôlable
j'ai fait des dizaines de game over
parce que tu passes ton temps à perdre
des vies pour rien le jeu est pas finie
en fait c'est tout le jeu pas fini il
manque le toit à la maison là il suffit
de voir des détails comme ça par exemple
ou bien c'est vraiment sérieusement
censés être des sables mouvants çà et là
pour moi je me tais les portes et c'est
quoi ces quêtes mémorise les chiffres
ajoute le second au quatrième si j'ai
pas payer pour l exercice le même bordel
et je vous jure
me relancer même pas sur le sujet de la
romance floue entre sonic et élise white
et c'est incroyable de voir ça sur xbox
360 sur nes ou sur la première
playstation à la limite mais là on est
sur xbox et sur une licence majeure et
c'est pas n'importe quel connard là
c'est sonic
en fait les gens qui ont créé ce jeu
n'ont simplement pas compris ce que
c'est qu'un jeu sonic parce que la base
des jeux sonic contrairement à ce que
tout le monde pense ça n'est pas la
vitesse c'est le level design et la
physique c'est de voir défiler le niveau
devant nos yeux on passe un lobbying on
enchaîne dans un tunnel nous envoie en
l'air et nous faire tomber pile sur un
ennemi et tout ça de manière fluide
c'est l'enchaînement qui est important
ici la vitesse au final ça n'est qu'une
récompense pour le joueur quand il
réussit à maîtriser le level design et
la physique du jeu et le problème des
jeux sonic c'est que contrairement à
mario ou zelda depuis leur passage à la
3d ceux ci n'ont jamais été réellement
constants alors oui il ya eu des sonic
3d qui ont fonctionné comme les sonic
adventure mais plutôt que de capitaliser
sur une formule qui marche comme ont su
faire des mario après mario 64 ans se
disant bon assez bon on a une base qui
marche on n'y touche plus et on affine
la formule est bien les jeux sonic eux
au contraire ils ont toujours eu
tendance à tout jeter tout recommencer
depuis le début à chaque nouveau jeu et
au final ben y'a jamais une progression
alors oui évidemment il ya eu des bons
sonic après ça un sonic générations
sonic magna mais après sonic 2006 sonic
et est officiellement devenu dans la
tête des gens une licence mineurs sont
jezzy quand un nouveau jeu mario soir
maintenant c'est l'événement tout le
monde en parle quand un nouveau sonic
sort c'est mais ok
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
quelque chose de gigantesque vient de
pénétrer l'atmosphère
il
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et sans transition et donc j'y viendrai
de pénétré l'atmosphère
il aurait apparemment la forme d'un
ministère
[Musique]
l'humanité est un cancer y moi je suis
le remède
heureusement pour nous
il n'y a pas de remède contre le cancer
comment comment saviez vous que le jem
et est ici depuis le début le seigneur
tanus savait exactement dans quel
entrepôts se trouvait là j'aime mais il
n'avait pas les moyens de lui redonner
sa forme originelle
alors grâce à l'intelligence de votre
serviteur se donner des informations
suffisantes à cannes arman tout on me
faisant quoi il s'agissait d'une
maladresse de georges tu sais qui une
maladresse la phase plein a désormais
terminé le tableau pensais que j'étais
un simple agent d'entretien
alors qu'en réalité j'étais un espion
envoyée par notre mère patrie la le sait
ce serait trop compliqué à expliquer il
est temps de mettre un point final à
cette histoire
et fondu pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi il
ne se passe rien évidemment que je ne
marche pas tanus
merci pour cette partie vieillard de
rien connard
je vous demande pardon hein non rien du
tout moi je à 6,6 il a dit de rien qu'au
narre obe super mais bravo à quoi ils
jouent en équipe à pourquoi vous l'avez
pas dit la première fois quand on est
allé vous chercher parce que seule cette
succession d'évènements comme était
d'aboutir notre seule et unique chance
vous avez oubliez ça
tenez moi cette gemme
[Musique]
parfois affronter la tête de tous les
bruits
[Musique]
oui
puis
[Musique]
vous
moreno
[Musique]
méchant
mais pas aller plus vite
c'est foutu
plus là c'est moi insectes
non
tana seul d'entre eux viennent nous
assistons montchamp tristan font tout
diktat de la nièvre ou du mec qui sort
canard
cette fois c'est fini pas encore comment
ces marionnettes
il nous reste un dernier chapitre à
écrire pour epifanio
[Musique]
où
vous avez réuni les quatre journées vous
commencez votre si l or noir
battre à fond
je souhaite je souhaite remercier tous
les gens qui nous suivent depuis 11 ans
maintenant c'est grâce à vous connaît
aujourd'hui
alors du fond du coeur mais j'ai mis pas
compris votre requête
ok alors je souhaite
[Musique]
alors je n'ai absolument rien contre et
à ton histoire mais du coup tu a
souhaité qu au final en fait un spécial
oh merde talent a pas marre de jouer ce
truc là ça fait combien de temps t'as
pas envie d'arrêter
[Musique]
bon
allez encore quelques parties
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un peu le poil qui sortent la
spirale de la mort de près on commence
cette semaine par une bonne référence
franco française
[Musique]